my name is Kevin Watkins I'm director of
the education for all global monitoring
report which is produced annually by
UNESCO and this is the education 101
lecture I want to start by just saying a
few words about the education for all
agenda that's the UN framework for
education it's a little bit broader than
the Millennium Development Goal
framework as a lot of you will know the
second millennium development goal sets
a target of universal primary education
by 2015 and there isn't there's another
goal that the names that gender parity
in education the education for all
system is a little bit broader it
includes what happens to children before
they get into school that is to say the
early childhood agenda it includes
learning achievement and the quality of
education in other words what what kids
get out of going into school but it also
includes measurements of progress and
setting benchmarks in areas like adult
literacy technical and vocational
education and training and the financing
of education so I want to start off by
just making a few general observations
about why education is so critical Mark
Twain once said that his real education
was about forgetting everything that
he'd learned in school but for millions
of kids around the world getting into
school and getting a decent education is
what really shapes your opportunities in
life and if you think about why
education is so central to the whole
Millennium Development Goal framework
get just think about the links from
education to some of the other goals we
have one of the Millennium Development
Goals which is about having extreme
poverty by 2015 now if you want to have
extreme poverty you need two things you
need economic growth and you need poor
people to share equitably in the
benefits of growth education is one of
the most powerful drivers for economic
growth around the world that's true for
rich countries
and for poor countries and we know from
the data in the analyses of many
countries around the world that it's
people without education who are getting
left behind so if we can't deliver
education to people living in poverty if
we can't move rapidly towards universal
primary education in the world's poorest
countries those two critical ingredients
of more accelerated economic growth and
fairer distribution are going to be
missing education is also of course a
basic human right in and of itself it's
something that people have a claim to
and entitlement to it's a provision in
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights and and that's another reason for
putting it right at the top of the
Millennium Development Goal agenda we
know from many of the other indicators
for measuring progress that its people
and parents with education who are in
the best position to expand
opportunities for themselves and for
their children if you take some very
basic indicators about child survival
having a mother who has been to
secondary school more or less cuts by a
factor of three to four the chances of
children dying before the age of five so
if you want to cut child mortality by
two-thirds which is one of the
Millennium Development Goals ensuring
that girls getting to school today in
order to improve child survival
prospects tomorrow is absolutely
critical as a key investment and of
course we know that education is one of
the key factors in political
accountability people who are deprived
of basic literacy and numeracy skills
are not well placed to hold their
governments to account and that's why
you eat when we think about governance
systems and good governance we really
need to think about education as part of
that overall framework as well now I
want to take you pretty quickly through
some of the key education for all goals
and then I want to come back to you know
what are some of the big impediment to
progress so I want to start off by
saying something about the progress that
we've made how far we have to go look it
look at some of the
good news and some of the bad news and
then I want to focus on the community in
the world that's being left behind the
most marginalized people in the world
let's start with early childhood often
when people think about progress in
education they start from what happens
to kids when they're in primary school
what is the intake rate into primary
school what is a transition rate from
primary school into secondary school and
those types of indicators and of course
those things are really important but
equally important is the condition of
children when they go into school and
around the world there is something
there's something like 178 million kids
every year whoo go whoo start their
primary school career carrying the
burden of extreme malnutrition that is
to say they've experienced acute hunger
at some stage in the first five years of
their life usually during the first two
years of their life and and that really
matters not just because of the
suffering that it inflicts on those
children not just because of the enhance
exposure to risk of infectious disease
that it that it creates but also because
we know from many studies that once a
child has been malnourished it
interrupts their cognitive development
and we know that the consequence of that
tracked children all the way through
school that kids who have been
malnourished perform at far lower levels
in terms of memory tests in terms of
writing in terms of numeracy than kids
who haven't been run nourished so if you
want to secure a proper return from
investments in education if you want
real opportunity real equality of
opportunity in education tackling that
crisis of malnutrition before the kids
get into school is absolutely critical
we know for many children that the
disadvantages that come with acute
malnutrition actually begin in the womb
that is to stay it starts with the
malnutrition
of their mothers that's an especially a
big concern in South Asia where iron
deficiency and micronutrient deficiency
is extremely widespread it affects
something like forty percent of pregnant
women in the South Asian region as a
whole and that has implications for the
development of children in the womb it
has implications for children being born
underweight and again we know that
children who are born underweight if you
pick up their test scores seven years
later ten years later even fifteen years
later you can still see that a big
disadvantage their nutrition related
disadvantage that's why in our in the
UNESCO education for all global
monitoring report we attach an awful lot
of weight to joining up the health
agenda and the education agenda if you
want to see kids flourishing in school
you need to make sure they're properly
nourished before they get into school
and if you want to make sure they're
properly nourished before they get into
school you need to you need to ensure
that their their mothers are properly
nourished during pregnancy and there are
many things that need to happen in order
to facilitate that maternal and child
health agenda but absolutely critical in
its context is the removal of fees on
basic maternal and child health care
many countries continue to charge
mothers for antenatal services that has
very adverse consequences for attendance
clinics and access to the services that
mothers and children need in order to
flourish we've seen on the other hand
that when those fees are withdrawn in
countries like Senegal Sierra Leone and
Liberia it really opens the door to the
health system to mothers with
significant improvements for child and
maternal health many governments around
the world are now recognizing that if
you want to tackle disadvantage in
education you have to start before kids
get into school that was actually one of
the central tenants of President
Johnson's had
starts programs in the United States
right back in the 1960s that if you want
to break this link between poverty on
the one side an education disadvantage
on the other you have to start early
before the the age of five and many
developing country governments are also
now trying to expand their their early
childhood education systems but
enrollment into those systems remains
very low and it also remains very
unequal if you look at a country like
Egypt children from the wealthiest
twenty percent of households in that
countries are 25 more times more likely
to being an early childhood class than
children from the poorest backgrounds
now that is a huge disadvantage for the
poor and of course it's precisely the
poor who face the risks of malnutrition
and who need the the additional support
that an early childhood education can
provide I want to turn now to universal
primary education which is one of the
areas where the education for all agenda
and the Millennium Development Goal
agenda meet if you look at the one of
the core indicators for progress towards
universal primary education it's the
number of children who are out of school
and we've seen significant progress in
this area over the past ten years out of
school numbers have dropped by something
like twenty eight percent and that's
very significant but I want to turn to
some bad news within that general good
news story if you looked at the global
picture for who was out of school back
in back at the end of the 1990s and the
the start of 2000 we had something like
105 million kids who are out of school
the vast majority of those kids were in
southwest at South and West Asia and
sub-saharan Africa and what we've seen
in the decade since is a really steady
improvement so out of school numbers are
now down to about 72
that's a big step forward you can see
from that chart that the step forward
however has been very uneven and it's
been uneven in two respects which is the
biggest gains have happened in South
Asia and West Asia especially in
countries like India and Bangladesh
which has been particularly successful
in cutting gender disparities in
education Africa's also been making
progress and really quite significant
progress because the primary school
population of sub-saharan Africa has
increased by something like 20 million
over that period and yet the
out-of-school numbers are coming down so
that's a real testament to progress in
in sub-saharan Africa you can see also
that the progress is uneven over time we
had this very big dip in out of school
numbers between about 2002 and 2005 but
after then the trend starts flattening
out and more recent dent more recent
data point to a continuation of that
slowed down so we started to see a
slowdown in the rate of progress around
the middle of this period and and and
that's continued now if you project this
forward to 2015 it gives you an idea of
where we might be if we carry on as we
are and this is what that projection
looked like you can see two things that
come out of that story the first is that
we're an awful long way from hitting the
target will we will still have over 50
million children out of school into in
2015 as if we carry on as we are the
share of African children in that out of
school number will continue to rise
steadily over time and that that's a
major concern because sub-saharan Africa
is already the most disadvantaged region
of the world in terms of education and
in an increasingly knowledge-based
global economy where prosperity
employment progress in areas like health
and others
indicators depend critically on
education these education gaps that that
graph captures in a very basic way will
of course translate into gaps in global
income distribution in marginalization
for the region and and disadvantages in
other areas as well I i should add to
this general picture which is not a good
news picture that the official data
probably understate the scale of the
problem and that's because what the
official data capture are the enrollment
rates that are recorded at the start of
a school year in other words they tell
us about children going into school if
you actually look at what household
survey data tell you about attendance in
school it turns out that there are
typically far fewer children actually in
school that are registered on on the
school accounts and reported to
governments we estimate in fact that the
understatement of the outer school
population is probably in the range of
thirty to fifty percent for most of the
countries that that we've looked at in
the report I focus so far on the
out-of-school numbers and that out of
school number is absolutely critical but
it's important to understand what do we
mean by the term universal primary
education it seems like a very simple
concept but it turns out to be not quite
as straightforward as we imagine in a
typical rich country kids will go into
primary school somewhere between the age
of five and seven and they'll stay in
and they'll stay in that school they'll
progress steadily through the system if
you look at the typical situation in a
developing country many kids go into
school very late and often they drop out
very early so the fact that you might
enroll into school in year one doesn't
actually tell you very much about your
prospects for completing a full primary
education cycle
and I want to illustrate that for you
with the example of Nicaragua so if we
take the primary school age group in the
cracker and we look how many of that
group actually enter primary school at
the right time it's something like
sixty-seven percent that is to say
around one third of Nicaraguan children
of primary school age are entering
school later than they should or not
entering school at all but then if you
track them through the system and you
ask the question well how many of those
kids actually get through to grade 5 the
survival rate to that grade is right
down to thirty two percent that is to
say only one third of that Co hall are
actually getting into school and
progressing through school and of course
getting into the last grade doesn't
necessarily mean you're going to get
through the last grade and it turns out
that only about one-quarter of children
get through the last grade so you can
see from that example just how seriously
the problem of retention in school is as
indicated by the high dropout rate and
in half of the countries of sub-saharan
Africa one-third or more of kids who go
into school drop out before completing
school so there's a twin challenge here
with regard to access to school and that
challenge is first of all about getting
kids who are out of school into the
school system the second challenge is
about ensuring that once they're in the
school system they stay in the system
and they progress steadily through the
grades to have an opportunity of making
it through to secondary school I want to
touch very briefly on some of the other
aspects of the education for all agenda
because I mean clearly education is not
just about what goes on in primary
school there are two other goals 3 goals
three and four on the education for all
framework that deal with you
than adults skills and literacy and
these are both areas where we've seen
progress but at the same time many
problems yeah so far I've been talking
about primary school-aged children who
don't make it through the system but if
you look at the adolescent age group we
have just as many kids in the adolescent
age range around 72 million who are out
of school and of course those are kids
who are coming out of the education
system and into employment markets and
they're entering those markets lacking
the basic resources that they really
need to secure a decent job decent
employment and work their way out of
poverty technical and vocational
training systems can provide these kids
with a second chance but once again the
evidence that we've got from many
low-income countries across a across
South Asia and sub-saharan Africa is
that relatively few kids are getting
into those technical vocational and
training systems and those that do get
into the systems are often coming out
lacking the basic skills still that they
need to secure a job we have the same
problems in literacy that we have in
other areas and indeed literacy has
really become a forgotten goal we've
seen very limited progress the ambition
of cutting literacy rates by around one
half which is the target most countries
across the world are an awful long way
off track for achieving that and there's
very little prospect of the big
illiteracy countries India Nigeria
Pakistan actually getting back on track
and achieving the target however we do
know from the success of some major
literacy programs in countries like
Brazil the rapid progress is possible
I mentioned before that gender parity in
education is one of the most critical
goals it's critical for education for
all framework and for the Millennium
Development Goal framework but it's
critical above all because it's a basic
human right the idea that your gender
should determine your opportunity in
education isn't is not one that most
people would accept and yet if you look
at the state of the world although we
have seen a big decline in gender
inequalities particularly in sub-saharan
Africa to some extent in South Asia
we're still around 6 million girls away
from gender parity that is to say if we
have the same proportion of girls in
school as boys there would be six
million more girls in school and there
are 28 countries in the world that have
9 that for every ten boys in school
there are only nine girls or fewer that
is a very significant gender gap the
final education for all goal that I want
to mention in passing relates to the
quality of education it goes without
saying I think that most parents want
their kids to go to school for what they
learn just being in school isn't isn't
an end in itself it's a means to
learning and it's a means for building
the skills and getting opportunities to
go into secondary education and yet we
know from the evidence of many countries
in particularly in the poorest parts of
the world that the quality of education
is letting an awful lot of kids down
they're coming out of school in many
cases having completed a full primary
cycle lacking basic numeracy skills and
lacking basic literacy skills there are
studies from India and Pakistan which
show that the majority of children in
grade 3 are unable to subtract simple
one digit sums to give you an
illustration of just how serious the
quality problem is and if you look at
what that means on a global scale here
we often look at inequalities in
education in terms of years in school or
Roman reigns in secondary education but
if you look at this graph it shows you
this is from an international learning
assessment survey called Tim's the
horizontal line rd marks where the
lowest benchmark for performance in
other words kids who are performing
below that line are performing below
what is regarded in the assessment as an
absolutely minimal level of achievement
and if you look at the OECD countries
over on the left-hand side of the graph
you can see that there are very tiny
populations who fall into that category
but if you look over to the right hand
side of the graph you can see that in a
country like Ghana ninety percent of
eighth grade students are actually
performing at below that lowest
benchmark level now once again if you
bear in mind that we're moving towards
or we're living in an increasingly
knowledge-based global economy and you
have such a big proportion of kids who
are in school who are learning it at
that sort of level and you compare their
learning achievement with kids in rich
countries these populations in future
will be competing in the global
marketplace and once again these
inequalities and disparities in
education will have consequences for
success in areas like international
trade and will have implications for the
global distribution of income so I want
to turn now to this key issue that it's
a pretty bleak picture out there if we
look at the rate of progress towards the
goals that the international community
has set itself and it immediately raises
the question well you know who is it
who's being left behind and why are they
being left behind and what can we do to
reach them and I wanted I want to cover
each of those areas in turn let's start
with reaching the marginalized one of
the things that we've done in UNESCO is
to develop a new measurement tool
which we call the deprivation and
marginalization in education measure and
we developed it not not just to capture
the level of disparities within
countries but in order to turn the
spotlight on exactly who is being left
behind and asking why they're being left
behind and I wanted to spend a little
bit of time explaining to you how this
Tool Works because I think it may be
very relevant to many of you who doing
research in education and are interested
in these inequalities of opportunity and
I want to look then at some of the
drivers of marginalization what is it
that is pushing some kids to the bottom
of the end of the distribution for
opportunities and then to turn to some
of the remedies so let's start with the
the deprivation and marginalization in
in education tool the first thing we do
is to ask the question how many children
are what proportion of the children in a
country have achieved less than four
years in school we look at this for the
17 to 22 year old age group because this
is an age group which of course is being
through the basic education cycle and it
gives us a snapshot of what's happening
in the education system that produced
them that they have gone through why for
years because we know from international
evidence that if you have less than four
years in school you're very unlikely to
emerge with the basic literacy and
numeracy skills that you will need to
flourish in society we we also look at
another measure which is the proportion
of children with less than two years in
school and we treat this as an extreme
education deprivation threshold I think
it goes without saying that if you have
less than two years in school you really
have very little prospect later in life
of having acquired the skills that you
can use for gainful employment to
improve your position and prospects in
in society we have a cluster
of countries in the graph that you can
see line up in different ways with
respect to these two indicators as you
can see if you go to the right-hand side
of the graph you've got countries like
Burkina Faso Chad Senegal all of which
have more than fifty percent of their 17
to 20 22 year old population with less
than four years in school over on the
right hand side you've got countries
like the Philippines Turkey Egypt and
Vietnam where the numbers are much lower
but the next question to ask of course
well is who is most likely who faces the
greatest risk in any society of getting
less than four years in school and one
way of asking that is just to look at
what's happening to the poorest twenty
percent this shows you for a small group
of countries what are the what's the
proportion of the poor is twenty percent
with less than four years in school and
you can see in a country like Yemen it
goes up for that group from around
thirty percent to sixty percent in other
words being born poor roughly doubles
your chances of getting less than four
years of school and this is the you can
see the effect as it plays out for the
wider group of countries but of course
it's not just poverty that matters in
many countries it's gender as well and
if you ask yourself if you ask what's
happening to the poorest twenty percent
of girls in these countries you see
another layer of deprivation in other
words over ninety percent of girls in
Yemen who have born poor and female at
the age of 17 to 22 have gained less
than four years in school so that gives
you an insight into the scale of the
wealth effect in education and the
gender effect in education at a broad
national level but I want to now mine
down a little bit deeper by looking at a
couple of specific countries because as
I said one of the advantages of this
measurement all is it enables you to
look behind the big Nash
numbers behind the national averages to
ask exactly who is being left behind and
how far are they being left behind so
let's look at Nigeria and you can see at
the bottom of this chart we D marked the
extreme education poverty line less than
two years in school and the education
poverty line less than four years in
school and we've lined up a group of
countries here we're on the y-axis on
the vertical axis you've got you've
you've got the years in school completed
by the average 17 to 22 year old in that
country it runs from about 13 in Ukraine
down to just over 2 in Chad and if you
put Nigeria on this scale you can see it
comes out on average just under seven
years in other words if you're if you're
born in Nigeria and you have average
chances in education you're going to get
just under seven years in school but of
course behind that average number you've
got very big differences you've got a
wealth gap so if you're born into the
rich is twenty percent you're going to
get almost ten years in school whereas
if you're born into the poorest twenty
percent you're going to get just three
and a half years in school if you break
that division down into the rural and
urban sectors of society you can see
there's quite a small gap between the
wealthy rural and wealthy urban people 8
17 to 22 but a very big gap between the
urban and rural poor being rural Paul
puts you two very big disadvantage
compared to the rest of society
including the rest of the poor is twenty
percent in Nigeria and you can see also
there's a very big wealth gap that poor
rural girls are right at the bottom of
the pile on these on these divisions
averaging less than three years in
school but then if you break that down
again and you go to northern Nigeria and
poor rural hauser girls who live in the
northern part of the country the most
educationally disadvantaged
part of the country you can see that
this is a community or constituency that
average is less than half a year in
school in other words if you're born
into a poor Hauser family in northern
Nigeria as a girl you're really right
you'll push right down towards the
bottom of the global distribution of
opportunity in education the this is
true across many countries of the world
if you look at a country like Turkey I
you you can you can see again the
rural-urban split the rich poor split
but then cutting across these you can
identify one of the most marginalized
groups in the country in terms of
education are poor Kurdish girls who on
average whereas Turkey as a whole as
averaging around eight years in
education poor Kurdish girls are
averaging well around three years and
actually are performing it around the
level of the average for country like
chat so in the midst of an OECD country
we're seeing education indicators for a
sizeable population group that would
compare pretty unfavorably with many
countries in sub-saharan Africa of
course these disadvantages that I'm
describing in education and which the
deprivation and marginalization index is
picking up are overlapping they don't
exist in isolation there's not a wealth
effect that's separate from agenda
effect and both wealth and gender
effects interact with other indicators
for disadvantaged whether you live in a
rural area or an urban area what
language you happen to speak in many
countries what ethnic group you happen
to come from and I want to illustrate
that by taking a cluster of countries
and looking at the risk of being in a
state of extreme education deprivation
in those countries so if we look at the
share the overall share of the
population in this group of countries
who
getting less than two years in school
you can see in Nigeria it's pretty high
it's around a quarter of the population
in Kenya is around eight percent of the
population much lower can drag garner at
seventeen percent India twenty percent
but then if you take particular groups
in those countries if we take Kenya if
you happen to be a rural somali girl
born into a poor household ninety-six
percent of those girls are going to have
less than two years in education that is
a an extraordinary level of inequality
it's almost as though there are two
education systems with that within one
country one pastoralist girls from poor
households were being left way behind
everybody else and another for the rest
of society and these measures are all
important I think because they give us a
window on that big global picture that I
was setting up earlier they partly help
us to address the question of who's out
of school exactly where do they live in
many cases what language they happen to
speak and how do we identify them so
what are the underlying causes of some
of these deprivation indicators that
we're picking up with that without
measurement tool of course we need to
avoid overgeneralization in this area
because every what all of these groups
have in common is that they're highly
marginalized and they're being left way
behind the rest of their country but
they all face very distinctive and
different types of problems and if we
want to resolve the problems the first
step of course is to understand them so
what what are the key themes that we we
pick up from our analysis of who's being
left behind we think you can broadly
divide this into five key areas some of
the effects are linked to overall
poverty and vulnerability and of course
it's poverty
that drives children from any of the
poorest countries into child labour and
there's a lot of evidence that children
who are pushed into child labour are
going to face really diminished
prospects of getting a decent education
there are specific group based
disadvantages if you happen to be born
into an ethnic minority if you happen to
be born into an indigenous group in many
countries in Latin America it carries
with it a much higher risk of
educational deprivation so we need to
understand what's going on within these
groups there are a whole range of
location and livelihood specific
problems it's an obvious thing to say
but if you're born in in a slum area
you're much more likely to be out of
school you're much less likely to
progress through primary school if you
do manage to get into school and much
less likely to get into secondary school
and there are some livelihoods in
particular the case of pastoral farmers
which I've already mentioned which carry
which appear to carry with it an
increased risk of being out of education
there are wider factors as well which
I'm not going to go into detail here but
in the the evidence from many poor
countries shows that there are
significant groups for example disabled
children who are much less likely to get
into the education system or children
who have been orphaned by HIV and AIDS
who lack the parental support who often
lack the resources to get into the
education system so I started off by
mentioning poverty as one of the biggest
barriers to education and we have still
over 1 billion people in the world who
are living on less than one dollar 25 a
day and if you look within these
households this of course is where the
problem of child labour is very heavily
concentrated there are around 116
million children of school going age who
aren't in school but are working and
what's pushing them out of school and
into work of course is their household
poverty and in some cases it's poverty
which is created
by external specific external shocks for
example a sickness episode in the
household the price of a commodity falls
a father loses their job now for a
family that's living below the poverty
line it's very unlikely to have the
assets or the resources that they need
to deal with that sort of shock without
making very tough and often damaging
decisions for long-term household
welfare you can cut nutrition you can
cut basic spending in other areas or you
can take children out of school and also
often of course families are forced to
make that that choice of taking kids out
of school we know from the data in many
countries that being born into a
linguistic or ethnic minority group
carries an enormous disadvantage
indigenous people in a country like
Guatemala on average are getting less
than half of the years in school as
non-indigenous people that's a very big
gap which is connected to the to the
group that they happen to be part of to
the language they happen to speak at at
home we know from the evidence in India
that the children who are most likely to
be left behind are low caste children
from poor households particularly in
rural areas now this is an area in which
there are many aspects of group based
marginalization which have big
consequences for education if you look
at the experience of many countries in
Latin America language has often been
one of the tools of cultural domination
and subordination and that's reflected
that has historically been reflected in
education systems which for example may
only offer teaching in Spanish which may
not be the home light which is not the
home language spoken by indigenous
people we know from the evidence of
studies in India that if you're born
into a low caste home and during a
school with children who aren't from the
same background as you but it come from
a higher caste back
ground that if your cast is actually
announced when learning assessments are
going on children are less likely to
perform well they're less likely to
perform well because of the lack of
confidence and the stigmatization in
that case that comes with their being
born into a low caste household and the
experience of being a low caste person
there is something like 900 million
people in the world who are living in
slums and living in a slum of course
carries many disadvantages which have
relevance for education parents are
likely to be poor and may not be in a
position to afford education children
are more likely to be sick but in many
cases slum dwellers are also are also
living in informal settlements and
living in your formal settlements may
mean that they don't have a registered
titled property right and that main term
deprive them of their entitlement to an
education because the funding of schools
is often linked to title to property
rights and and so on so that carries a
very big disadvantage I've already
mentioned the issues of disability and
hiv/aids which are widespread problems
particularly in the case of hiv/aids in
in sub-saharan Africa when many children
are living every day with the
consequences of having been orphaned and
the lack of support that that results in
what are some of the remedies the things
that governments can do across the world
to tackle these issues of
marginalization with what one way of
thinking about this is in the form of a
policy triangle there are things that
governments can do to enhance access and
affordability to make schools more
affordable for poor children to ensure
that classrooms are available to poor
children and so on there are things that
governments can do to enhance the
learning environment to ensure that kids
who get into class really get a chance
to learn in class and there are things
that need to happen much more broadly to
tackle the underlying causes
disadvantage the kids take with them
into the education system just to
mention a couple of points in each of
these areas if we take the learning
environment we know the children
particularly during the first three
years of their education really need to
be taught in the language with which
they're most familiar that is to say
their home language and in many
countries across the world that have
introduced home language teaching
Vietnam Bolivia Ethiopia Eritrea we've
actually seen quite significant
improvements in tesco test scores within
the school system of course in order to
teach children in their home language
you have to recruit teachers who can
speak that language that means focusing
more on recruiting teachers from
indigenous minority groups and we've
seen a very big push in countries like
Peru and Bolivia in Latin America to
create teacher training colleges for
training indigenous teachers and
creating incentive systems to keep them
within the school system within the
education system and to get them out to
the communities who really need their
their support schools of course need to
be properly financed and that's
particularly true of poorly performing
schools in highly vulnerable and
marginalized areas there are a number of
governments across the world that have
introduced capitation financing systems
Ghana is a very good example of that
that has increased the resourcing to the
poorest parts of the country the
northern Ghana in this case and that is
also starting to show some results both
in terms of the numbers of children in
school but the learning outcomes in the
school system as well if you take the
bottom left-hand corner of the triangle
the access and affordability point one
of the things the government's can most
obviously do to improve affordability is
to ensure that children don't have to
pay to go to primary school there's a
lot of evidence from across the world
that where governments charge kids for
going into school it is a very big
deterrent it creates a very big barrier
to entry but we also know that when that
barrier is removed it can really result
in surges into the school system when
Tanzania removed school fees in around
2003 2004 it led to an increase of
around 3 million children going into the
school system over the next four years
something broad is similar to that
happened at around the same time in
Ethiopia and looking back a little bit
further precisely the same experiences
were repeated in countries like Malawi
and Uganda now getting more kids into
school it's clearly a good thing but
when you have a surge in enrollment like
that you can put a group of very great
strain on the school infrastructure
class sizes go up you can get shortages
of books of desks of basic teaching
materials and and so on and it's very
important therefore the government
sequence and plan for these surges in
the case of Ethiopia there was a very
heavy investment put into training
teachers in advance and making sure that
qualified teachers were available in the
first one in the first grade a second
grade and the third grade why was it so
important to get qualified teachers in
those grades because the evidence from
many countries as shown that when you
get these surges the second that you do
an assessment test as a condition for
going on to the next grade you can see
very big dropout levels that's still a
problem in Uganda where as both Tanzania
and Ethiopia have avoided that problem
precisely by investing far more heavily
in getting qualified teachers into the
early grades and supporting early grade
learning the broader entitlements and
opportunities framework it's not enough
in many cases just to take away formal
school fees things have to be done that
protect the most margin
and vulnerable families from the impact
of economic shocks and one of the things
that governments can do here is to
invest in social protection systems
we've seen evidence from countries like
Brazil and Mexico and more recently from
Ethiopia in Zambia in sub-saharan Africa
the targeted support for poor households
can enable these very poor can enable
very poor communities to withstand the
shocks that might otherwise force them
to withdraw their children from school
legal provisions can be incredibly
important India has produced a law
requiring all state governments to
provide basic education for children
that was already in the Indian
Constitution but it's now part of the
legal system and the children though the
parents of children who are unable to go
to school kit can now actually take out
legal action against state governments
and a demand that they fulfill their
obligations and under a legal
entitlement so the law can also play a
key role and we know of calls from the
history of many rich countries if you
think of the civil rights movement in
the United States for example that legal
entitlements can make a very big
difference in terms of overcoming social
inequalities over and above what
developing country governments can do
and should do to reach their most modern
my citizens the aid community in the
international community also has a
critical role to play back in two
thousand when governments from around
the world signed up for the education
for all agenda under a document called
the Dakar framework for action there was
a pledge made which was actually a
really critical one and was something of
a breakthrough and the pledge said that
no country that is fully committed to
achieving the education for all goals
would be allowed to fail for want of
finance that was a commitment from the
donor community from rich countries not
just a developing country governments
but to the children of
alican countries now that pledge has not
been honored and I want to give you some
of the basic indicators for just for the
degree to which it's been broken look in
our last education for all global
monitoring report we we looked at the
financing requirements for achieving
basic education on some of these key
targets that I set out earlier and we
did that for 46 low-income countries and
if you take these countries that as a
group the overall financing requirement
is somewhere in the order of around 36
billion US dollars these are average
annual financing requirements through to
2015 the current resources which are
going in to basic education in these
countries is somewhere in the order of
around 12 billion u.s. dollars if you
factor in towards 2015 the additional
resources that would be generated by
economic growth and the revenue
collected from that growth then put back
through the national budget into the
education system that would push up the
financing available by around another 3
billion and we also estimated that if
governments were to strengthen their own
revenue raising efforts and provide more
equitable public spending with a
stronger focus on basic education
something like another 4 billion could
be mobilized of course these numbers all
look different for individual countries
but this is averaged out across the
group of 46 countries but if you take
that financing base you can see it's an
awful long way from where governments
need to be in order to deliver on the
promise of education for all in fact
it's around sixteen billion dollars away
from where it needs to be and it's this
sixteen billion dollars we should really
provide the benchmark for the
international aid effort in a
education but if you if you unpick the
international aid effort in education
you can see that it's falling an awful
long way short from where it needs to be
so current aid to education for those 46
countries that I mentioned for basic
education is running at about 3 billion
dollars you may remember that back in
2005 rich countries made a number of aid
pledges I under the gleneagles framework
and other commitments but even if those
pledges were delivered on in full and
the evidence for sub-saharan Africa so
far is that less than half of their
commitment has been delivered but even
if that were changed it would only
deliver another two billion dollars in
other words that leaves us with an aid
shortfall for financing in basic
education for those 46 low-income
countries around 11 billion dollars
annually that that's a very small sum of
money when you compare it with the money
that was pumped into the banking systems
of rich countries for the financial
rescue package during the during the
financial crisis it's a tiny sum of
money when you compare it from with
global military budgets but it's a very
large chunk of the overall financing
that's required in order to move us
towards this ambition of education for
all by 2015 if you look behind again
behind this this headline number two the
performance of individual donors and aid
for education is partly a function of
the overall aid effort and it's partly a
function of how much of the overall aid
effort goes into the education system if
you look at the overall aid effort you
you can see there's a very variable
level of performance among donors this
is measuring aid as a percentage of
gross national income and you can see
that it ranges from almost one percent
or around one percent in the case of law
way too well to well under 0.2% in the
case of other in the case of meat some
major g8 economies like the United
States Italy and Japan many of these
donors have set individual targets or
adopted group based targets are
increasing their aid effort these blue
dots give you an indication of where the
bar has been set as you can see some
donors who are scoring pretty low on the
share of national income that's going
into aid and set the bar quite high like
Italy others have said it very low like
the United States but if you look at how
countries are performing against where
they've set the bar in some cases
there's really almost no progress like
as with the case of Italy in others
there's more progress in countries like
Spain the United Kingdom France and
Germany but the overall story here is is
one of an impending shortfall the
commitment to double aid to sub-saharan
Africa will not materialize if donors
carry on as they are and that has huge
implications for the financing gap that
I outlined a little bit earlier the
trends in aid to education are a source
of rising concern in 2006 and leading
into 2007 we saw a big decline in aid
commitments to education which you can
see picked up in in this graph here and
the decline was particularly marked in
the case of a basic education and this
year we've updated these figures to look
at actual delivery and that stagnation
has been continued now if you look at
these trends against the financing gap
numbers that I outlined earlier you can
really see we're an awful long there's a
very large deficit between what the
donor community is actually doing and
what it promised to do back in two
thousand and closing that deficit
at a time of fiscal stress in rich
countries obviously poses they raises a
lot of tough political questions it
raises questions of prioritization and
some governments the United Kingdom in
particular has made very strong
commitments to keep to its pre-crisis
aid commitment targets and is aiming to
achieve the 0.7 target by 2013 that is
to say to spend 0.7 percent of national
income on aid by 2013 other major g7
countries are in danger of missing that
target France and Germany in particular
and another group of countries major g8
economies United States Italy and Japan
are really signaled that they're now
extremely unlikely to be moving towards
the targets on or anything like the
scale required it raises the question of
course of do we need to look beyond
traditional aid bilateral aid national
aid that goes through the multilateral
system to more innovative sources of
financing in the health sector there's
been quite a strong record of
performance on mobilizing new resources
through facilities like the Global Fund
for example for tackling HIV and AIDS
for the GAVI initiative to support
vaccination financing so far we've seen
really nothing like that in education
and I'd seems to me there's a real
opportunity there to start tapping into
innovative financing resources and
getting it into the education system
looking beyond the headline numbers on
aid there's another set of issues that
really need to be addressed urgently
what one of those issues is about the
predictability of aid it's absolutely
critical for education planners in poor
countries that you know how much aid is
going to be coming into the system over
the next three to four to five years and
that's for very obvious reason that if
you recruit teachers today you still
need you need to be paying them in three
four
five years time unfortunately much of
the aid that's committed to low-income
countries and in particular into
education has a very high level of
variability in volatility attached to it
which makes planning very difficult
there's also a tendency on the part of
many donors to work outside of the
government budget system and the
government financial planning system
which is undermining efforts to build
capacity in education and their whole
groups of countries that are being
either bypassed by the aid system are
not sufficiently supported and that's a
specially true of conflict affected
countries and countries that are
emerging from conflict so I've tried to
set out during the lecture some of the
things the government's and aid donors
can do to tackle the problem and just to
summarize the the broad framework I
think there are six key points that need
to be made the first is that education
is a basic human right the feature of a
basic human right is that it's a right
for everybody in society what you
achieve in education and your
opportunities in education shouldn't be
determined by the wealth of the
household that you're born into it
shouldn't be determined by the color of
your skin or the language that you
happen to speak or your gender or where
you happen to live and that's why we've
been arguing in the UNESCO education for
all global monitoring report for equity
based targets these could be targets at
a supplementary to the Millennium
Development Goals which might include a
provision like having the gap in school
attendance between the wealthiest
children from the wealthiest households
and the poorest households having the
gap between the rural parts of the
country and the urban areas of a country
setting such a target would be important
symbolically because it would be sending
a signal that we care about equity we
don't just carry out the national
average but it would also help to turn
the political spotlight on those groups
that are being left behind the group
that are picked up in our deprivation
and marginalization in education
indicator a second absolute priority is
to strengthen the commitment to quality
at the moment we're achieving far more
progress on the headcount indicators of
advanced we're getting more children
into school we're getting more children
through primary school and we're getting
more children into secondary school
that's all positive but far too many
children are still coming out of primary
school lacking the basic tools that they
need the literacy tools the numeracy the
numeracy tools the reasoning tools and
the and the broader problem solving
competencies that they need to realize
their potential international learning
assessments can give us a window on the
scale of the problem and the global
inequalities in this area but what is
really needed is national and local
learning assessments that gives us a
clearer picture of where children are
but critically those assessments have to
be linked to the building of capacity
the training of teachers the provision
of learning devices in order to raise
overall quality standards it's
especially important that we tackle this
problem early early learning assessments
and early learning support is key here
because if you fall behind in those
first two or three years in primary
school it's increasingly difficult to
catch up and again we've seen from a
number of countries that concentrating
resources in the early years can really
make a difference in terms of raising
overall learning achievement levels it's
it's important when we look at a problem
like marginalization in education not to
think in silos it's seldom the case the
children who are being left behind in
school face one problem they carry with
them into school the underlying
structures of disadvantage that they
experience in their households
disadvantages of poverty disadvantages
of discrimination in some cases based on
the color of their skin in some cases
based on the language they happen to
speak the group that they happen to
belong to there are issues of
stigmatization and self-confidence and
it's important the policy makers when
they think about strategies for closing
gaps and enabling the marginalized to
catch up that they tackle all of these
problems simultaneously of course that's
a tough thing to do the thinking in
boxes and operating in silos isn't going
to solve the problem in many countries
governments even governments that are
strongly committed to the to the goals
of the education for all agenda and to
the Millennium Development Goals like
the capacity to deliver the resources
and the financing and the services that
are needed to give kids a chance to
deliver on the right to education but in
many of these countries we're seeing
non-government organizations
community-based organizations stepping
up to the plate and in cases like
Bangladesh in Zambia in Tanzania these
organizations are often reaching
children who are highly marginalized
children who are living in slums in the
case of Bangladesh living on riverbanks
providing training but also through
cooperation with government operating on
the national curriculum and getting
those kids back into the school system
and it's important i think that
governments and ngos work in partnership
that they operate in tandem and they
don't operate on separate tracks
increasing resource mobilisation every
country resource mobilization is another
key issue of course every country in the
world has to determine its own
priorities but many countries are
attaching far too little weight to
education India is spending less than
three percent of national income on
education that is too little and
ultimately it'll backfire because it
will hold back employment creation and
economic growth in India it'll certainly
hold back efforts to create a more
broad-based equitable pattern of income
distribution there are many things the
government's can do to expand financing
for education it's partly about
broadening the tax base it's partly
about determining or redefining
priorities between areas like military
spending and spending on school systems
but we also need to see the donor
community stepping up to the plate and
delivering on the commitments that it
made we're currently facing an overall
financing gap in education beyond that
that particular group of countries that
I outlined earlier around 13 billion
dollars annually that's a small sum
compared to what rich countries spent
bailing out their banks but it can make
an awful an awful lot of difference to
the lives of those 50 million children
who will still be out of school in 2015
if we don't fix the system and put in
place the financing now so we need to
honor those overall financing
commitments the last point to make on
all of this is that this is not a
problem for tomorrow we are now less
than one primary school generation away
from breaking the promise that was made
back in 2002 delivered decent quality
basic education for every child in the
world we can't wait until 2013 or 2015
to put in place the investments that are
needed to provide education for all
bye-bye 2015 we need to do it now we
need to act with urgency and we need to
keep the promise that was made to the
world's children thank you very much